welcome back to episode number 11 of the
beginner to master speedrun I'm coming
into today rated
870 so hopefully I can break
900 and let's hop into the first
game
playing a series of numbers followed by
ABC okay we have a Kings Pawn opening
opponent rated
962 and I'm going to stick with most
principal chests defend the pawn control
the
center and there's a lot of moves white
can play here there's D4 there's Italian
there's a
Spanish there's potentially the three
Knights or four Knights uh here we have
the scotch which is also very
playable and from this position there
are a few moves for black um I've
noticed a lot of beginners like to just
trade which is not not actually a good
option even though it would prompt the
queen to come out early it would
basically surrender the center and white
would be very happy to go into that so
the move I like to play here is Bishop
to C5 uh very simply developing
attacking the Knight the alternative
would have been Knight to
F6 but um yeah this is a uh a playable
line white takes on
C6 and in this position there is a
somewhat surprising move because I could
take the
Knight but as far as I know the the
theoretical approach is actually to play
Queen
F6 and obviously I am threatening Maiden
one uh but the point of this move is
there's cases where I want to take back
with the D pawn and not allow the Queens
to get traded and there's no way for
white to save the Knight and the pawn in
a single move here like Knight D4 I can
take
it so pretty sure there's been like a
number of grandmas games that have
featured this
position and unfortunately for my
opponent uh yeah we have a somewhat
reversed version of Scholars
mate um I feel a little bit bad it
reminds me of that
game was it moist critical against xqc
very similar line
no please don't it's too
soon it's too soon Hikaru I think that
game featured like this and then this
and then this and then this and then
checkmates might have to search the clip
on YouTube we didn't even reach a
climax but yeah from the white
perspective
my
opponent okay after Bishop
C5 my opponent should be aware of the
threats except the fact that the Knight
will not be saved um I think there's a
few options for white like Queen to F3
is a Mainline Queen D2 or queen E2 also
playable um but it was necessary to
defend F2 so that was a quick one six
move game to start the
video uh let's move on another 10 minut
game playing
bmt2 seem like my opponent pre-m moved
Knight C6 which is known as a nimich
defense um against this I mean the most
principal move is D4 I could also play
Knight F3 and maybe try and transpose
back into an E4 opening or E4 E5
opening um let's play D4 I I'll stick
with principal
chess and P very quickly plays
D5 and this is a playable move this is
aiming to maybe go into a Scandinavian
type opening if I take then the queen
would take and then the pawn is
hit
so I've had this position before and I'm
going to play a move
that I very much like for white is just
to defend the pawn with Knight
C3 and this is a move that a lot of
players
maybe aren't used to encountering who
play this defense as
black and one of the points is I don't
have to take back on e4 right away I'm
actually very happy to play Pawn
D5 attacking the Knight and getting
ready to take although I probably don't
want to take right away because then
that would give black the chance to take
on D5 and then I would be down a pawn so
with the Knight coming to
B4 um it is attacking the pawn but my
Pawn is defended enough times here so I
think I'm happy to play
A3 simply kicking the Knight if takes
I'll win the Knight and if Knight
A6 then I can recapture and then yeah
the D5 Pawn is defended everything
should be
good so I'm pretty sure instead of
Knight B4 my opponent should have played
Knight E5
to keep the Knight more
centralized Knight A6 is probably the
best move here but as a the old saying
goes Knights on the rim are very
Grim or very dim dim Grim kind of the
same thing okay so we see Bishop
F5 attacking my undefended
knight and here I do have some
options I'm somewhat tempted to throw in
the
check because then black would have to
play C6 or Bishop
D7 I mean another very logical move is
to play Knight
G3 and then if the bishop moves back
then Bishop B5 could maybe be a lot more
powerful because then then there's no
Bishop
D7 like Bishop B5 Bishop
D7 I don't want to be just developing
and then Trading
so yeah I like the fact of um even
though I'm retreating the Knight I am
keeping
initiative opponent defends the
bishop so again if I play Bishop B5
black can block the check but if I take
the bishop first black will likely take
back and then I check and then there's
only two legal moves for black imagine
C6 is played and then I
take man that's actually not super
simple cuz black could take take and
then queenside Castle I think it's still
good for me I'll win a pawn in that
variation that was a somewhat deep
calculation but let's go into
this I mean this line is pretty
forcing opponent's taking time I have
taken a decent amount of time to play
this opening but um yeah hopefully the
the calculations pay off C6 played very
quickly and let's go into
this I'm curious if my opponent will
find the the best
continuation there's really not another
great option for
black uh even here cuz I'm threatening
to take unleashing the bishop and then
queening so my opponent does find Queen
side
castling and now I do have to be
careful just with the defile like if I
play Bishop D2 they could be Bishop
H6 but then Knight F3
defends I think I would rather just play
King
E2 and
normally like it's not great
to quote unquote Bon Cloud the king like
this like putting the King on E2 but
with Queen's off the board it's kind of
hard for back to exploit the king and
meanwhile opponent just gave a free
Knight and maybe it's this king that's a
bit more exploitable cuz I can develop
with
Tempo check to the
king if King B6 then I could
Retreat
E5 E5 is sometimes a nice
idea with the idea to pin the bishop but
I take on E5 it's check and it's a
double attack I'll be winning The Rook
on
h8 yeah let's take this Rook show no
mercy and if Rook E8 check then I can
hide on F1 life will be
good
okay still have to watch out for what
black wants to do Rook is attacking the
bishop so let's drop it back to very
nice Central
Square attacking the
pawn um although I probably don't want
to take the pawn because Rook A8 would
skew the
Bishops but there's no reason to do
anything like too crazy here it's
important to just complete development
get the Rooks into play
just want to make sure Black's not
attacking anything like everything is
pretty much defended I'll play
H3 kick the
Knight if Knight D4 I probably don't
mind
trading I should say Knight
E5 although with Knight E5 I could trade
but I could also pin the Knight and then
have three attackers against a pinned
piece
which perhaps is a bit more
attractive okay so we see Knight
H6 and there's a lot of options here I
mean I could take the Free
Pawn but I'm more inclined to just get
uh Rooks into play if I can trade off
Black's Rook then it'll make life a bit
easier in in
converting okay now I'll take the
pawn again attacking The Rook
and I'll try and win this game as
efficiently as
possible um cuz already like the king
might be running short on
squares and I'll set up a nice trap here
I'm going to centralize a knight this
does obstruct the Bishop from defending
the pawn it does allow black to take on
B2 uh but the point is then I have 96
check with a discovered attack against
B2 and yeah black falls into it oh no my
Pawn but oh no box Rook now I am going
to lose a bishop on
A6 but that's a another good trade for
me now I'm up two Rooks in this
position and in terms of
the the strategy to
win um not only win but win quickly
I think i' I'd like to go for some
trades try and trade off the
Bishops this is another case where I can
say oh no my Pawn if black takes it then
the bishop will be
lost so it's a nice thing about being up
material is I have a lot of pieces to
generate tactics
with and this is just uh yeah downward
spiraling for
black opponent attacks the bishop
I'll take with
check not giving time black time for
black to take the
bishop and now again I don't want to
overthink things I'm going to just play
Bishop F4 which keeps the Knight very
restricted and let's save The
Rook might as well might as well take
the pawn it's a free
Pawn attacking the
knights the the Knight is almost trapped
like I'm controlling all these
squares the only safe Square for the
Knight is
h8 will my opponent find
it Knight h8 would allow Knight G6 the
next
move I mean at this point I'm more
focused on forming some kind of
checkmating
that and I think the best way to do that
is to bring in
in the other
rook and I could start with Rook to
B1 uh but one thing to kind of think
about here
is what available squares does the king
have currently the King has three legal
moves I'm controlling the file taking
away
C5 so I actually really like the idea
of kind of boxing in the king even more
so now I'm controlling the squares on
the C file and the squares on the a file
so Rook B1 is actually Checkmate here
it's um one of the more efficient ways
to
win there's sometimes where you have to
watch out for like trapping the king too
much and creating stalemates but we were
not close to stalemate given that the
Knight and the H Pawn could still move
and the C Pawn so I think that was a
pretty clean game
um got a nice position from the opening
opponent allowed me to expand and attack
the Knight sometimes expanding like this
can be weakening because it's
overextending but in this case Pawn was
well supported and really paid off gave
a nice
position uh and then this
sequence I do want to give kudos to my
opponent for finding Queen side casting
but in this position I think it was the
biggest blunder for my opponent
instead of taking the pawn black
probably should have moved the
Knight something like Knight C7 to save
the Knight attack the bishop I would
have taken and white would be up a pawn
here but it would still be a a bigger
fight given that um yeah it's like
almost equal material black has a bit
more development as
well so um getting closer to
900 let's go
again playing some random goofy cat
person okay curious what random goofy
opening we have a scan
navian yeah with Scandinavian I like to
uh very simply attack the queen right
away we see Queen
d8 I know uh fellow International Master
John Bartholomew is a big proponent not
only as a SC but of this specific
line um it's not the most aggressive
line like black just spent two tempy
moving the queen back and
forth but yeah maybe it's playable E5
comes very
quickly this is interesting so black is
sacrificing a
pawn to then maybe trade Queens
but I think I'm very happy just to win
the pawn and then the Queen trade I mean
should favor the side who's up
material and I don't have to take with
the King here I think I'd rather
preserve casting rights and I'll take
with the
Knight even though it looks a little bit
weird having the Knight on the back
rank um I'd much rather be able to
Castle Queen side or King side in the
near
future so black does attack the
pawn and I would like to somehow develop
and defend the
pawn if I play Knight F3 black could
develop again thre to double the pawns
also threat to take and win the pawn so
even though Knight F3 is very
natural I think I like Bishop F4 a bit
more because it's harder to exploit the
bishop here and it gets me one step
closer to cing Queen
side F5 interesting I wonder if my
opponent is hoping take on passant so
the Knight can
develop but on pasant is
enforced and now it's a question which
minor piece do I want to
develop I mean these moves come to
[Music]
mind but if we think about what black
wants to do like what development scheme
black is going for I think it's likely
black wants to play Bishop e E6 and
Castle Queen side so I have a developing
move here to prevent black from playing
Bishop E6 which is Bishop
C4 and the downside of having played F5
is that the the Pawn's not supporting E6
so this diagonal is just much
weaker and we'll see how black continues
here yeah Knight E7 I was going to say
Knight E7 is probably the best
approach going for Knight G6 to attack
the bishop and the
pawn so it's not easy to stop Knight
G6 but I imagine there should be some
ways to deal with
it like for one now I can
develop and then if Knight G6 is
played the pawn will be defended and I
can play a move like G3 just to
reinforce a bishop
let's go for this I mean sometimes
playing a move like G3 is a bit
ugly okay in this case it won't be
necessary but I was going to say that um
G3 would just keep everything
defended we see here black going for
Bishop
G7 which I don't think I mind let's
develop the
Knight I'm bringing the Knight to
C3 because the prospect of Knight B5
looks really
nice like if I get in this move then
it's not easy for black to defend the ca
Pawn like the only way to defend the
pawn would be king d8 and yeah with
Bishop G7 like Black's not threatening
to take Black's not even like ready to
Castle because this bishop is so strong
so let's go on the
offensive my opponent is at the rating
where they'll very very clearly see the
threats I'm expecting King d8 maybe King
D7 here uh the drawback of these moves
is it puts a king on the open file for
my rook and then I'll Queens side castle
with
check and that should be very very nice
so I'm not sure like what the best move
is for black best move might be Rook B8
allow this and then run this way but
it's not
pretty we do see King
d8
I mean if I want to I could start with
Knight
G5 but I think castling it's kind of
ironic that I'm getting my king safe and
exploiting Black's King always feels
good to castle with
cck and here there's a a pretty
devastating move for black pawn E6 a
very Feelgood move for me so I'm
attacking the pinned Bishop I'm also
unleashing the attack against C
s but I might as well might as well
start with taking the bishop with
check and it's about to be an all you
can buffet in Black's territory now I
can take the pawn with
check and yeah the only legal move is
King f8 and I was ready to take the
Rook so pretty quick game and we see an
example of like even when Queens are
traded
early it can still be possible to attack
and the attack worked out partly because
I was controlling more space had more
development and black just didn't get
the pieces to good squares in time to
like defend and I think one of the big
positional
mistakes was uh playing
F5 CU it really just didn't have a
purpose and and weaken the position a
little bit too
much um maybe if La started with 97 this
would be a bit more practical preparing
Knight G6 eventually the bishop could
develop here in Castle and then it would
be a bigger
fight so I've broken
900 uh Let's do let's do one more
feeling good playing Kim Day Rated
965 and I'm sticking with cl
openings you see Bishop to C4 The
Bishop's
opening with Knight F6 I'm already
preventing these
Shenanigans so doesn't make sense for
white to develop the
queen and let's play a two knights
defense this does give white the option
of playing a fried
liver okay
so we do have um
what could be the beginning of a fried
liver now the best move here of course I
have to address the fact that my pawns
attacked so the best move is
D5 um I
believe I mean I know that there's
another move Bishop to C5 this is called
the Traxler but not going to play it in
this
game and in this position the pawn takes
and a lot of players go wrong here in
recapturing D5
and the reason why taking on D5 is a
mistake is it allows this very nice
trick Knight takes F7 King takes F7 then
Queen F3 which I believe I showed in a
previous episode so I'm going to play
the main line here Knight to
A5 and we're actually following the game
between uh Ali Resa fua and favano
Carana from the sinkfield cup a couple
days ago but this is a very common line
at at amateur level but also at
Grandmaster level and it can be a very
sharp
opening cuz I lost a pawn and I'm not
necessarily winning it back I'm in check
here um best move is to play
C6 and in some sense this is a Gambit to
take on
C6 attacking the
bishop now the nice thing about this for
black
is I have initiative The Bishop's
attacked it's probably going to have to
move and then I can continue by kicking
the Knight and for the next several
moves there will hopefully be some um
some nice Initiative for
black now I don't actually remember the
theory
here I know Bishop D3 is like one of the
like the most topical
moves at high level
so I mean so far this is not at all a
beginner level game from either of us
like we're I think we're still following
grandmas level
Theory one of the points of Bishop D3 is
white can respond with Knight
E4 uh rather than having to go back to
F3 or
H3 and in this
[Music]
position I'll say that I'm on my own
like I I don't remember any specific
prep but I can think about this
logically is I'm down upon if I
trade that's one line to consider but I
think that just favors white because I
clarify the position and one of the
drawbacks for white is this bishop on D3
is in the way of the Queens side
development it blocks a pawn which in
turn blocks lightw Bishop so I think I'm
happy here to play Knight to
D5 and even though this movees the same
piece twice I am perhaps violating some
opening principle I do have the idea of
playing Knight F4 to attack the bishop
on top of that I do have ideas also of
playing F5 to harass a knight but I have
to be careful playing F5 too soon
because it would allow Queen H5
check so
here I guess I have to choose do I want
to play Knight F4 immediately or
complete
development if I play Knight F4
immediately there's Bishop
[Music]
E2 I think I'd rather
develop and still got to focus on
opening principles like get the king
safe and then as we approach the middle
game I'll decide whether to go for
Knight F4 or go for F5 to um like
aggressive moves to attack White
Knight C3 does hit my knight but I'm
going to leave the
tension and just
Castle I really wouldn't mind if we
trade and then I get the two Pawns in
the
center and with the King castled now F5
seems a lot more feasible then don't
have to worry about Queen H5
check
and yeah F5 would probably Force the
Knight back to G3
okay
B3 and we could still be following
Theory probably have to check after the
game if this is still some theoretical
line so I'm debating here between F5 and
Knight to
F4 both moves do look
Pleasant
if I play F5 we can imagine Knight
G3 and then I have some choices like I
could go for
E4 I could follow through with Knight
[Music]
F4 I think the lines are very similar
I'm going to start with F5 because I
think it's a move that I'll play
eventually and I'm not sure if I want to
keep the Knight here or if I want to
commit it to F4
so after Knight G3 I I do have a
decision to
make yeah I could also consider taking
the
Knight and then after take play a move
like
E4 I'm imagining Bishop C4 then white
gets triple
pawns so let's calculate takes takes
E4 probably Bishop
E2
not 100%
sure this is definitely one of the the
more challenging games I've played so
far in this
series going to try and manage my time
here not get too low on
time so I'm looking at Knight F4 Bishop
E2 it's like a question how do I get my
other minor pieces into play
I play E4 maybe something like E4 Bishop
E2 and then Bishop
F6 looks
reasonable yeah let's start with
E4 so I like the prospect of gaining
space and opening the diagonal for my
Bishop okay so we see Bishop C4 which
I'm very happy about cuz now I can trade
off my knight which was very Grim on the
rim and now I can take and triple
White's pawns and I'll still be down
upon Pawn like I have six pawns white
has seven pawns
still but white has triple pawns on the
C file so like these pawns don't really
count towards being worth three
pawns and I also have the bishop
hair so I think from here I just want to
get the Bishops to good
squares let's start with Bishop to
E6 I mean if I wanted to I could have
traded but if white wants to trade then
I'll be happy to get the
defile and in the meantime I'm attacking
the pawn on
C4 so we might see a move like Queen to
E2 or a move like Bishop B2 but yeah the
problem with this
is it leaves a pawn hanging and The
Bishop's not going to have much of a
life being blocked by the ca
pawn and I'm attacking The
Rook so I imagine we'll see either Rook
E1 maybe Queen dig
C8 I am falling below four minutes
White's playing aggressively attacking
the pawn on F5
so there's a few ways to address this I
mean queen D5 or queen A5 would
defend oh but also do I just take the
Rook
immediately I almost forgot I was
attacking The Rook yeah I'm going to
take the Rook even though this might
allow like the pawn to come here and
white to try and orchestrate a kingside
attack I should have enough ways to
defend and rather than Direct directly
defending the pawn I'm going to play
Queen
E8 which just offers the queen trade and
it doesn't give white any time to take
the
pawn of course the queen can't take CU
Rook defends if Knight takes I win the
queen and if takes I'll take with this
rook and the pawn will stay defended
pretty much every
line so White's playing very wisely um
avoiding the queen trade which usually
makes sense when you're down material
you want to uh keep heos on the
board also when you're up on time you
want to keep pil on the board trying to
have a longer game so I'm playing Queen
G6 to align with the King maybe someday
getting in F4 and
F3 I also defended the pawn so Queen is
not able to take on
C6 I think the plan going forward from
here is to try and Advance on the king
side um now I don't want to play f42
quickly because it allows Knight takes
E4 but something like
Rook
ae8 just getting the Rook behind the
pawn okay white unleashed the diagonal
but I'm okay with that going play Bishop
D6 really just trying to optimize the
pieces now I'm very much ready to
play Pawn
F4 okay why is attacking the G
Pawn if I play F4 I don't want things to
get too
messy so let's there's a few moves here
I could offer the bishop
trade I think I'd much rather just
defend with the
Rook my Bishop is useful in preventing
KN
F4
also notice how all my major pieces are
in light squares so the bishop can't
physically exploit them or physically
attack
them a downside of um of having a bishop
only move on the same color
square and now with Knight coming
back I'm ready to play Pawn F4 Rook E8
over defended the E Pawn
now I think white is in a lot of
trouble if Knight goes back to H5 I
would have played F3 in this case I'm
happy to
take I could also play Pawn F3
[Music]
here do I want to play Pawn F3
first it would threaten
Checkmate yeah I think I
do
I was about to just take the Knight
but uh sometimes when you see a good
move you want to look for the best move
in this case I'm threatening Checkmate
I'm also threatening the
queen so winning the queen or
checkmating is much more valuable than
just winning the
Knight and even if white plays this like
fancy looking KN F6 check I would take
it f Pawn's still supported ma is still
thre
okay so now I I just have to move
quickly enough not to lose on
time but this is still plenty of
time especially being up a lot of
material although if I take the Knight I
do allow white to
take so do I want to
keep my Rook on the
board now let's simplify we
take allowing white to take but then the
king will be a bit more
exposed and I'm going to employ The Rook
lift here Rook lift is simply when you
move up and then
over really just trying to generate some
checkmating
idea but if I can get the Rook here and
queen here there's going to be
some hopefully eventual checkmating
ideas
and there's not really much the bishop
can do to help defend I mean maybe white
can try King H1 Rook
G1 uh let's start with Queen
F4 just want to take on
F3 think maybe the point of this move is
yeah the king wants to run this way the
problem for white is I'm cutting off the
king and queen H1 checkmates I believe
is
Unstoppable I'm not pre-moving it
because there is Bishop
E5 but uh yeah Checkmate is coming very
[Music]
soon I mean this was a very good game I
think uh this was one of the most
challenging games for me in the
speedrun I don't think there's been a
game so far in the series where I've
gotten this low on
time and it seemed like my
opponent either like knew the opening
pretty well or was able to figure out
the opening quite
well but still managed to
Prevail and I
think I mean without checking with
engine I think like one of the key
mistakes was Bishop
C4 allowing this transformation where
white got triple pawns like if Bishop
E2 I wasn't so sure how to proceed like
I really want to prepare F4 but then E4
would hang White's ready to maybe at
some point play D3
so if we go
back um
checking I don't know if there's an
opening book
here okay I'm checking with the engine
[Music]
so yeah white was slightly better out of
the opening okay we do have the eval
bar but it was very close to
equal and yeah the engine does not like
this bishop C4
move as we see the I mean we definitely
saw the downside of the the triple pawns
and then here probably white should play
Queen E2 engine's actually saying Bishop
F4 just stay more in the
center but um anyway I think this is a
nice example of one of the main lines in
the two knights defense
and I should note that for those that
are maybe new to this
opening uh you should not play Knight
takes D5 as black even though it's kind
of playable it runs into this trick for
white and yeah the best move is King E6
and black is under serious pressure with
Knight C3 so I I did not want to be
entering that in in this game so anyway
I think this is a good point to wrap
things up uh thanks so much for watching
hope you learned a thing or two and stay
tuned for more see you soon